auf den ersten blick wirkt er ganz
harmlos matthias ilgen spd-politiker aus
schleswig holstein und jetzt einer von
230 neuen abgeordneten im deutschen
bundestag
aber wenn matthias ilgen seine brille
abnimmt dann kann es gefährlich werden
bis vor einem jahr zog der spd politiker
als wrestler durch die lande
seine gegner nimmt er knallhart ran und
scheut keine fiesen tricks um sie zu
bezwingen
wenn irgend selbst zu boden geht ist
jubel garantiert denn in der show welt
des wrestlings ist er immer der böse mal
mein alter ego also einmal sehr
überspitzt das gegenteil von dem wie ich
eigentlich sonst zu binden aber es macht
schon spaß die rolle darzustellen und
mal derjenige zu sein der auch ein
bisschen dampf ablassen kann die sau
rauslassen kann ein bisschen die fiese
spieler drauf hat sage ich mal in seinem
anderen leben ist er hier zu hause
husum die kleine stadt direkt an der
nordsee ist irgend wahlkreis die meisten
husumer kennen ihn nur als freundlichen
kommunalpolitiker seine politischen
weggefährten aber wissen von irgend
doppelleben als fieser freiherr auch der
husumer bürgermeister
der bürgermeister ist überzeugt ganz
ungewöhnliches hobby werde ihm in berlin
sicher zugute kommen
finde ich grandios und die tatsache dass
er so eine interessante sportliche vor
karriere hat hat ihn ja nun in den
letzten wochen für die medien total
interessant gemacht also mich wie
normaler kommt wir da hinten hin und
setzt sich dahin sondern ist gleich in
aller munde und weltbekannt finde ich
klasse
anders als der westler möchte der
politiker irgend durchaus gemacht werden
deshalb ist er oft in seinem wahlkreis
unterwegs er will hören was die menschen
bewegt auch diejenigen die offenbar
nicht zur stammklientel der spd gehören
dass er im ring schwere brocken bewegen
kann hat eben oft gezeigt jetzt aber
soll er fingerspitzengefühl beweisen
beim krabbeln
in der tat seine fähigkeiten sind eher
größerer natur verbunden mit viel
theatralik
helmut schmidt hat man diesen spruch
geprägt dass politiker sind statt
schauspieler war das da ist natürlich
was dran also ein bisschen inszenierung
wenn sie vor publikum auftreten sprechen
und so weiter gehört dazu tat kann man
eine menge lernen also wenn man so
auftritt vor 34 500 1000 worden im regen
sozusagen drauf hat ist das auch mit
plattform dass man also freie rede
halten kann vor einem bundestagsplenum
aber soweit ist es noch nicht als neues
mitglied der spd fraktion ist irgend
erst einmal hinterbänkler
trotzdem haben viele parlamentarier
kollegen bereits von dem ehemaligen
wessler aus friesland gehört eine
reizvolle zusätzliche darstellung des
deutschen volkes und seiner fülle und
preise aber hier wird der nicht in
sondern hier wird der politisch kräftig
mitarbeiten dass darauf kommt es an das
ist entscheidend matthias eben möchte
sich im bundestag vor allem um die
themen wirtschaft und infrastruktur
kümmern und für eine gerechtere
solidarische gesellschaft kämpfen
ein kampf bei dem es auf andere dinge
ankommt als rohe kräfte hier ist
natürlich die sprache die vor allem
sozusagen das federführende instrument
ist im ring ist das alles aus seinen
kampfanzug hat matthias eben vorerst an
den nagel gehängt
denn als abgeordneter bleibe ihm für das
aufwendige westling training einfach
keine zeit mehr
deshalb will der 29 jährige künftig nur
noch im bundestag seinen mann stehen und
hofft dabei anders als im ring keine
buhrufe zu ernten